cette nouvelle plateforme Lidl située à
abli à côté de Rambouillet devrait
bientôt voir le jour elle sera la plus
grande plateforme de ravitaillement de
France pour l'enseigne et
approvisionnera l'Île-de-France et la
Normandie c'est une plateforme qui va
représenter à peu près 90000 m² de
superficie et qui va nous permettre de
mettre en œuvre toutes les familles de
produits qu'on travaille chez lidol au
total 300 salariés dont des alternants
sont attendus 250 emplois sont à
pourvoir dans la logistique en CDI au
sein de cette plateforme logistique de
87 1 m Carr salariés et alternants
seront avant tout formés l'entreprise
veut mettre en avant le bien-être de ses
salariés on construit la plateforme en
ayant unique dans dans notre esprit le
bien-être de nos employés vous avez vu
tout à l'heure les salles de PAE on fait
des grandes salles de pause on essaie de
réfléchir à la façon dont les gens vont
travailler effectivement mais comment on
va les faire intégrer cette plateforme
logistique c'est extrêmement compliqué
de découvrir un univers comme celui-là
donc il y a besoin de les intégrer il y
a besoin de les former il y a besoin de
les accompagner et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment au centre de nos
intérêts aujourd'hui selon le maire de
la commune la création de ces 300
emplois est un vrai plus pour la ville
c'est
réellement un plaisir de voir d'avoir
sur sur la commune une un lieu aussi
aussi magnifique la plantation de Lidl
est aussi considérée comme une bonne
nouvelle par la Chambre du Commerce et
de l'Industrie des ivelines AL au-delà
de la plateforme logistique je pense
c'est quand même l'emploi qui est
généré vis-à-vis à la fois des des
jeunes puisque il y a quand même un un
gros projet de recrutement de de jeunes
en alternance donc
l'apprentissage ça c'est une des
priorités de la Chambre de commerce les
responsables de Lidl devraient commencer
les recrutements début avril